okay
for people who are joining this meeting
we are talking about orphan language
design
for symbolic music so
um let's look at the questions here
because these are the immediate
questions i have
yep
ah this isn't gonna cut it i mean
we need a compatible design we're not
gonna just make a completely new design
so all right um
no no not the right design approach you
know we'll
we'll figure out what we need and then
we'll figure out how to make a bridge
we're not going to say
oh no we're going to deprecate this not
not no no
that was not the the what was intended
uh the two designs should talk to each
other and
sound nodes should be understood by one
framework and the
potential new design should be
understood by sound
yeah all right okay i'm just saying that
the specification is
is not very compatible with the
uh what we have in mind for now
and i think the objection was more about
making sound note
uh backwards compatible not breaking
from what we have had for a very long
time
only backward compatible yep what would
you mean backward compatible
the the sound we don't want to make
changes in sound note
that any other previous specification is
not going to work anymore
of course yep
okay all right
okay let's launch into the proposed
architecture
so i'm trying to understand a couple of
things so in wolfen alpha i mean there's
one thing
is reasoning about music and the other
is
uh you know
actually rendering music is that a fair
statement i mean in other words
yeah so so for for the reasoning about
music there is some code
for displaying and rendering music there
is a
very very limited set of capabilities
that we have
the whole music type setting problem is
pretty gigantic and
i'm aware yeah i'm aware i mean i know
we interacted with the lily pond folk
long long ago and we've interacted with
other people who do this it must be a
decade ago
um and that should be um um
um but let me give some examples of
things i mean
so in wolf and alpha we clearly have
you know i mean i can say you know a
b-flat
minor scale or something and it knows
what i'm talking about
sure right and presumably that's part of
this design as well
sure those things should we should be
present in the system as knowledge right
no no no no but what i'm saying is
just like we have synthetic geometry and
we have actualized geometry
right we need a similar kind of thing
for music that is we need to be able to
say
you know i have an abstract
you know scale of this kind and so on
right just like we can in wolfen alpha i
mean if we go to wolfman alpha
we can um you know we can say
now
we can say is there a minor scale i
don't know i don't know my music theory
well enough i
did once but i don't know now but okay
there we go
okay so now
i know all the things that are here
should be readily computable is that
part of your design or not
uh i mean it depends on how this would
return this
in with this design this could return
a list of music notes and then you could
easily compute
intervals between them um
[Music]
right let me tell for example yeah
i'm not seeing here any of the
functionality i would expect to see
that it's things like take a music note
okay so what you have is a concept here
of a pitch
and yeah i'm not buying a lot of the
stuff
okay so and why is this any different
from sound note
so first of all the pitch specification
is different second of all the duration
why is it different i mean can't i just
say sound note of c
sure sure okay fine the the numbering is
is different what numbering i don't see
any numbering here
sure the numbering that we would use uh
this
that is used in sound note is something
that exists
exclusively in sound what is usually
used is the midi numbering system
who cares we've got of many numbering we
can use midi numbering we can perfectly
well
that works just fine that is not midi
numbering
um that is different there is a because
it's an offset that
is not present in in any other kind of
numbering
okay well it's just enough important
things right it's not problematic
the specification that we would like to
uh a specification level that we would
like to have is not just
specifying the pitch it would be nice to
be able to specify
separately the pitch class and the
octave for example
and potentially alterations to that
pitch as a separate attribute
um what kind of the simplest case
i would say hold on hold on the renderer
that we have for this
are we making our own renderer or are we
using some kind of system renderer
uh you mean for playing or for this just
for playing it
at the moment we are using a midi
synthesizer
we just uh to play sound uh we
temporarily export to midi file and play
that midi file with the synthesizer
but so the things you're proposing which
are annotations to the notes
are things that are representable in
midi or not
yes
built this um 30 years ago right
there were many limitations on what midi
could represent absolutely
and for example what i was saying about
pitch class and octave those two are
relevant
for midi are just a different way to
represent a single note right
there's nothing different from saying c
c
or saying pitch class c an octave
um but it i
one of the ideas behind having a more
complex representation of
pitch is that it would allow um
let me know you know
all of this audio generator stuff i do
not use
right i find myself using you know
things where i'm just saying play a
function
because it's too damn complicated to
figure out how to use that stuff
let's not repeat that mistake
okay that stuff is is fine low-level
stuff it's not what we should expose to
users
i mean i have no idea why i'm using you
know audio generator of sign
it's because we have some partial
language right we don't have a full
language that we can use we only have a
partial language
where just having some particular
generators right
uh no you could uh put a check an
arbitrary function there
well then why isn't it just i mean okay
i mean i find this really difficult to
use i'm not
maybe we need to improve the
documentation because what you're saying
is completely allow you
you could this supports any kind of uh
function that produces uh
then why do we have both play and this
so play um does not generate an audio
object right
well that is correct right now what does
it generate
it creates a sampled sound object what's
the difference in a sampled sound object
or an audio object
object built by one team and one was
built by another team well
i mean one uh
can support files the other cannot one
can support different types of data
i was why was sampled sound
not just turned into an audio object why
was play not made to just return an
audio object
rather than the people couldn't be
bothered to to change it we could easily
do that
i don't know that decision was made
before i joined okay
well i'm i'm gonna i'm pushing back very
strongly on this idea of you know
i mean we need a design that's going to
work
you know the existing design is very
usable
something where everything has to be
annotated you know
65 times isn't going to be usable so
let's not break what we already have
which is quite usable
so okay the one um
argument that i would have against that
point
um is that you're seeing a lot of
complications right there
i i agree with that however
my main reason for this complication is
that
in my mind main source of uh
music is existing files scores that one
already has rather than
the user painstakingly but i'm not sure
that's the right the right approach for
us
i mean i agree that the analysis of
existing scores is interesting
yes we need a way to represent existing
scores yes
but much of that representation will be
under the hood
because you know you import a score i'm
hoping you'll get
something which visually looks
i mean you know where basically what we
have is some kind of music object
yes and that was the idea to hide this
complication in
an output form if you just import stuff
right
right but to me the you know graphs
are a good example of something somewhat
like this that is
if you look at you know if you make a
random graph
now here i actually don't know and don't
care what the input form of this is
so i'm saying okay some complicated
thing with sparse arrays
right but the reason i don't care is
because the accessor functions i mean
i'm i'm always using this with various
kinds of
access or functions so i'm saying yeah
so i guess the idea that i had in mind
was slightly different
where rather than building a gigantic
list of music-specific functions
have instead having an architecture of
uh
reasonably simple heads that then can be
used with functional programming and
their usual
replace nest map and all that problem
yes we need that but i mean
that that's okay so maybe that's
sufficient i don't know
i mean you know to what extent
should we think about music like we
think about geo
positions that is
is music does music
relate to audio
as geo positions relate to graphics for
example relate to geometry
is that a reasonable analogy i would say
not uh the the direction between music
and audio
is much fuzzier than geoposition and
graphics
there is a lot of um performance
dependent on their audio output
and how it relates the music like the
same score can be interpretable in
thousands of different ways you can do
different geo projections
you can do different your projections
sure there is a valid point
but but let's misunderstood your your
argument then
well no i mean i'm just trying to
understand because what we do
you know i mean it's an interesting
thing to what extent we've been able to
use
geometry to um
uh um
you know to deal with geographic objects
but but okay let before i keep objecting
let me let me look at what your
i mean part of what we need to do
okay you're thinking very much about
playing music
there's also the pure symbolic
computation
of things like these scales and so on i
mean
music theory the things you need for
like doing
thinking about music theory absolutely
go ahead and and the whole music theory
uh angle that i had was uh
biased from like importing squares and
analyzing those curves within
music theory lens okay like that is the
kind of application that i
right but we also got to have the simple
case of just doing
you know music theory as we can in
wolfen alpha for example
i mean that is not as much as music
theory as
a bunch of facts about a music object
no but there's a certain amount i mean
look look
if i do this
um right that needs
things like that need to work sure sure
okay that's fair and that's for example
the primitives about the pitch right
about how pitches interact with each
other and how you sum them and
computing intervals and and having named
intervals to
uh move from pitch to pitch right well
that makes it seem a little bit more
like date objects i mean it's like
saying
you know today plus
you know yes three days right
and i was wondering how much can we
borrow or steal or add i guess to
quantity both in terms of pitches and
durations
do we have anybody here who's who uh is
a
expert on the quantity framework
i don't think so i think we have used it
a lot but
so i don't know i don't think why not
yeah i mean i would think that
um um
right so so i mean to me it's important
that we be able to have something like
where you can say something like you
know music
note b flat or something and then where
that comes back as some symbolic object
i mean for example one question is
should music notes be entities
well that is
this is more similar to the to the date
object yeah where you have the
like for example yeah i kind of agree
with you
you need internal options to define the
scale and some other things
yeah i think i think it might be more
similar to a molecule or something where
we're not
where that is not where there is an
entity version of it
i mean i could imagine something where
there's an entity
what's that i could see that duality
having both as a
an object and an entity uh
that seems reasonable um
one thing that we were kind of um
i i kind of thought it would be pretty
important is being able to
underspecify all these objects like for
example you're saying music note of
uh b-flat that is an excellent example
a music note uh could have attributes
that span both the pitch and the
duration in this case you only specified
uh the pitch and there is a perfectly
valid object so yeah that is one of the
properties that we want to preserve
well i mean i would i would i would have
assumed that
you know this thing if i just hit shift
enter
is going to be a generic b flat it's not
saying if it's being played in a trumpet
it's not saying
it's lasting 10 seconds say what octave
it is
right just like in a geometric
characteristics i would say
but but in a geometric scene i can say
there's a point labeled a
and i say nothing about where it is yes
same kind of thing okay so then for this
i should be able to do computations with
this like add
five semitones or something and um i
mean i i'm assuming that we actually
have the notion of five semitones here
yes we do and um and then
we'll need to expand on that because
there are named intervals
as well right right so that's an
interesting question i mean plus uh
you know a major fifth for example i
mean if i type in i i wonder whether
this whether it does anything
if i say major argue that this could
also be a nice head like music interval
and then
they takes whatever of those yeah i
think that's a good idea
to have that be a music interval because
i think then if if the concept is
and maybe that's a little bit like a
date go ahead what are you going to say
yeah yeah no i agree it should be like
uh
the whole the difference between
um an absolute date and a time
difference
it's the same kind of thing absolutely
what i was going to say is
this whole computation with pitches this
all
hides away um all the subtleties
about tunings and temperaments indeed
absolutely just like but but i would
like to point out to you
that the same is true with geo positions
right
if i give a geo position that i'm not
telling you what datum that's in et
cetera et cetera et cetera
absolutely and this is what i'm saying
we should be able to
compute all of these complicated
properties etc
but as you were displaying before we
should have an
easy access version of it that hides all
of those away as
for example default values for options
and stuff like that
right but i mean things like temperament
is precisely is very very close
to me to to datums for for uh
geodata it kind of is it kind of isn't
in the sense that with different
temperaments
the you might get different names of
notes as well
um why if you do it with
literal hurts you will do that but not
not if you're dealing with the notes
symbolically right it doesn't make any
difference how it's tuned
no it does it does for example you could
have
a a a b flat or an a sharp they could be
different notes
oh god depending on the temperance
despite
that's that's a subtle thing so i mean
exactly this is what it is
to hide no but wait a second in in usual
midi
right yeah you know b flat and a sharp
are considered the same or not they
should be
yes i mean they're just a numbered note
in videos
you could specify them as different as
um
by uh defining a node plus an offset
and the other thing i want to point out
is that media as you mentioned before
is a kind of a crude representation of
music uh
what we are starting to look at to
for a better representation of the
subtleties of music
is music xml that packs much more data
about this then fair enough but but i
think
the important thing you know the
difference between
a sharp and b flat is
you know at the simplest you know that
is again
very much the same kind of story as geo
grids and all this kind of thing that is
there's some you know there's some way
of representing something and ultimately
it has to be rendered
into a particular frequency
yes and that seems like the same type of
thing go ahead
the two frequencies can be different
depending on no no i i
understand that i understand i mean and
you know with one
effectively datum those two things map
to the same frequency and with another
they don't
that is correct and one of the maps to
some complicated you know
uh you know thing from a piccolo and one
thing maps to something from a trumpet
and so on i mean the
the very different wave forms and so on
in the end
that depending on how it's rendered
right so i mean there's in the rendering
pipeline
look there's the symbolic representation
of the note
in which for example for example one of
the questions would be
there's the question if i type you know
music note of a sharp
right it is not going to symbolically
know that that is the same as b flat
it's not going to conclude that um
it isn't unless you specify a
temperament for
which that statement is true
sorry i'm sorry yeah i understand that
but but then so there's a question of
how that simplification works and so on
yeah absolutely yes i mean it can work
in
in equal or something like that like the
the the thing is it can stay
a a sharp and b flat but uh i don't know
for for date objects we assume a default
calendar which is
uh gregorian i assume yeah correct
so could you could assume the default
imperative
temperament yeah and uh i mean the
question is
yeah right exactly so if by default it
might work that way
and and and much like i mean much like
we do with a calendar
if i say here if i say i'm not sure i
know how to do this but if i say date
object how do i do this actually today
and then i say um calendar type yeah
calendar type arrow boy why don't we
have it more listed here we have so many
calendars now
that's a by the way can somebody report
that as a bug because we've got just a
gazillion calendars now so we might as
well
uh advertise that in the autocomplete
yep i got it
okay so there we go for some other
calendar system
and i i don't know what happens i assume
that if we say
that uh that will be the same day
as today right should we have
we also have a date equal is that do i
remember correctly
i don't think we have a date equal we
have a date i was convinced
no no we don't we have we have other
things that will canonicalize that date
yeah so one of the one of one proposal
that
the proposals that floated around was uh
some kind of music simplify as you said
to confirm
and uh um well i would think that we
could
okay so look look there's several
different things so so one thing would
be
you imported a score it's full of all
kinds of meta crud
right all kinds of things about you know
uh whatever and
all you want is i just want the sequence
of notes
and i'm going to do some whole elaborate
analysis on it absolutely
this is a crucial application i agree
but but i mean but then you know you
might also want to study the metadata
yes now i mean again
the thing we never got to right so so in
wolfen alpha
you know we're dealing with individual
notes we're dealing with scales things
like that we're not dealing with pieces
of music
yes good action um
and and so what you're proposing here so
so you have a hierarchy here
presumably music score is presumably the
the highest level in the hierarchy is
that correct
what and um
uh okay and you think the rest is at the
same level as a note is that yeah
couldn't figure out a good way to indent
everything what's that
i couldn't find a good way to indent
properly but yeah okay we're fine but
the hierarchy is you know a score
contains multiple voices a voice is made
from a sequence of measures um
and the measures contain sequences of
notes
and each measure would contain things
like um what signature
is being used and so on is that right
and which might yeah the signature could
be a property of the voice and then it
is unfair for each measure belonging to
that voice etc etc but yes
um yes what you're saying is correct but
then
when we have down to the raw note the
raw note could be
you know you write c but is actually
given the signature
you actually mean a different note isn't
that correct
um not
really like a the the
the key will just um
affect how the note is displayed
but if you write c that is a c the the
key
signature of the of the voice doesn't
affect
the note wait a minute wait a minute am
i totally
confused i mean if if there's a if
there's a key signature and it has a
bunch of sharps
marked on the you know when you write
out the music yes but
that affects just the rendering that
just means that when
the note is displayed on the on
underscore you don't have to repeat that
sharp every time you play it
no i understand that but but but when
you write the score
in i mean when you just write it out
okay you're saying when you give that
score in midi
i would write c sharp but when i write
it out
in you know in handwritten music i don't
i just write the the you know the c
the note on the c line so to speak
and the point is that the key signature
at the beginning of the of the voice is
just kind of a shorthand notation that
means no i get it i get it but you're
saying that one wouldn't ever want to
say here's the thing as it will be
written
away from the key signature so to speak
now apply the key signature you're
saying whenever you do that on a
computer
you um i mean what what music theory i
ever learned was long before computers
did these things
and by the way the person that really
here
knows everything okay so we've got a
hierarchy of people
as well as of of um levels here
yeah i don't there's never a useful
reason to to um
you know put a note in as see if what
you mean is c
sharp okay yeah it's only for the
writing it's only when you write it out
by hand that you would do that
that's right so you'll never store store
a c sharp as a c
like uh the sharpness is an attribute of
the of c
it's yeah yeah it's again it's the
distinct
so but on the other hand
um yeah all right fine
okay so so what what do we want to start
so so one thing is the symbolic version
of a music note
that presumably would display with some
blob
and would have the ability to be
specialized to a particular octave
to a particular you know tuning system
etc etc etc
but one could argue that those should be
uh the specifications should happen
within the pitch
not the note um right so
you say music note of music pitch so you
know no
you don't get to do that that's that's
making crud that will make it unusable
okay it's making crud that's making it
unusable don't go there
you know maybe it can turn into
something like that but that's not what
you're gonna enter
fine sure the entering mechanism is
could be different
i'm what i'm talking about is the
internal representation of it
what is inside that blob well fine it as
i said before i don't think it matters
so much what's inside the blob
if there are things that say for example
so what i'm not seeing here is a
property that just says
frequency or something or whatever
whatever we want to call that
right i want to get out i want to know
you know
in you know if if this was uh you know
a pure tone which won't be what it's
rendered as in
in the you know a typical music font
right were it rendered as a pure tone
what frequency will it be
yeah that's the kind of thing we got to
be able to get out from and presumably
that's the kind of thing where we'd like
to get that out for a music
score we'd like to be able to say you
know
were this being rendered by an extremely
boring instrument that's just generating
pure tones
what would the sequence of pure tones be
absolutely
um and then presumably what we want
is just like audio i mean if i if i say
um you know if i say speech synthesize
you know if i'd say this i'm presumably
i'm going to get an audio object out
and i can you know um and so presumably
what's the analog of that um
in i'm just thinking about this so so
presumably we'll have a music synthesize
which will generate an audio object
sound
take that um as an input right
and transform it into a playable sound
object
no what are you saying i don't
understand what are you saying so
so what you're saying you say you have
your music you want something that plays
it
right is that correct yeah just a second
i mean
yeah boy there's a different music there
okay sorry what were you saying so you
have a music score you want to transform
it in something that plays
right there are two forms of playing one
is sampled sound
an audio object um
another is
the media representation the midi
playback that can be converted to
sample sound by just sampling the output
of the synthesizer
and that is what audio of sound does if
you do
audio of sound node that should already
work okay
so okay so fine so if i say table
sound uh
that's not what i do
yeah sound a table okay so let's say
sound note
i point 1
table i 10 or something and i don't know
that i set
okay and then if i say spectrogram of
that
what a mess yeah the synthesizer is not
amazing
well i don't know what i i can't tell
whether that's a mess but i mean are we
using some kind of sound
music font or something sound font to do
these or is that
how does it work yes that is the sound
fund yes
okay fine so so that's the way so i mean
we're we're agreeing then that something
like
music score i mean in the end we'll be
able to say something like
audio of music score is that true that's
uncontroversial as long as we have a
synthesizer that i mean and
and already a lot of our audio functions
take the sound object
in anyways i guess they could eventually
get music scores as well
and just render them right
i mean i look i'm not totally opposed to
having a music note separate from a
sound note
not totally opposed but i'm a little bit
unhappy about it
the big issue with sound note in my
opinion well
as i said the picture shoot is pretty
minor the duration issue
um sound note takes a duration in actual
seconds
which is as far as possible as from the
uh duration kind of notation that you
get in
in a square where the duration is
relative to the measure
and to the uh to the tempo as a
subdivision of the tempo of the skull
right by the way most people on our
livestream are mentioning
a whole bunch of systems that
i'm sure many people know something
about
like super collider no i think nobody's
mentioned max nsp but they might have
done
um and uh uh you mentioned music
xml um and maximum speed don't deal as
much with uh symbolic music
right they're dealing with audio um and
they are and the
capabilities we have for audio we
believe cover those quite well
is that a true statement that is
reasonable i'm sure there are some
things that we cannot do that they can
do i'm sure about some things that we
can do that they cannot do but it's
i would say it should be reasonably
comparable
um the thing that is missing that we
don't have is real time
application of those things yes
okay so i mean
right and they're questions about uh you
know
formal theories of harmony and things
like that and how you would apply those
to
to i mean you know we would like it to
be the case that if you specify a little
piece of
music you can go and you know add in
i don't know what they all are you know
inversions and this isn't that generated
counterpoint from melody and stuff like
that
yes i mean but presumably the way that
would look
for us is there would be something which
is a
uh okay actually let me ask a naive
question is there a
standard string version of
a piece of music or is there no standard
string version of it
i think as in i don't mean a stringed
instrument i mean you know something
like
uh you know is there a standard way of
writing out a musical score
just like for chemicals you know there's
something like smiles there's a standard
way for writing out a chemical
it's not there's not one standard i mean
you could argue that music xml
is the closest to the standard okay fine
but it's an xml which is a big
hairy creature yes it is right so it's
not something where people type it in oh
it's a quick way to type it in just like
from molecules you could use smiles
to type them in quickly so to speak yeah
there's a notations
uh system uh that you lilly pond uses
that's
that's that's just strings of text
is it reasonable or is it grotesque it's
very reasonable it's very usable and
it's
programmable and it's expensive you know
extensible and
which is yeah it's a notation that that
you can parse very
very readily and and you can parse by
eye as well so
um okay so it's something people might i
mean people who actually
okay when people actually write music do
they always use
you know i mean i guess some uh you know
in modern times do they always like just
point and click with a gui or do they
sometimes type in this this textual form
i mean i'm assuming a lot of people just
record midi right you could
input it from a keyboard
right
um i i think and and rebecca and philip
correct me if i wrong i think
the options are uh one record from a
keyboard two
use a graphical interface like finality
values of music where you can
place your notes on the staff
right okay so it's not people are not
like it's not like command line music
programmers
actually so lily pond very frequently
you'll you'll write
writes your score as text it's actually
okay so that is the case but that does
happen the more obscure case
no no well okay so if you use if you're
going to be
creating scores um
i mean a lot of
computer specialists who go and get into
music they very quickly
gravitate toward lily pond because
because of
that that program for things like
all the max msps and super colliders and
so on in this world
we presumably already have exchange
formats that work like midi is an
obvious exchange format that we've had
for 25 years or something
is that correct yeah you could play a
midi file from maximus p
right but i mean is there is there some
other higher level form i mean do they
deal with music xml on that msp
is geared towards live performance right
so
um the the two um
uh ways of controlling parameters in a
synthesizer
live are midi and uh
okay i'm forgetting the name of the
other protocol that is more recent
um let me google it i forgot your name
complaining
okay any case then
um okay so let's come back to what we
need to figure out here so so
again the rendering
of i mean you know we have these
symbolic names for notes
we have the question of how the notes
will be rendered into frequencies which
depends on
tuning systems and so on if i'm not
mistaken
right so so i'm not seeing here oh yeah
we do have tuning system right there
you could argue that those could be
properties of the objects right
yeah i agree so i mean i i think it
would be just like we can say geo
position blah blah blah
and we can say um uh what is it geo
what is it called what is the thing
called when you set the datum for a geo
position i think maybe just give it
directly in the geo position
i'm not sure oh yeah the datum is just a
second argument to the geoposition
right
the other the other protocol to control
synthesizer is
open sound control osc okay but i mean
so so this is
this is what okay so this tells us
given this these geo coordinates that
will tell us what the actual
position relative to the center of the
earth is right
and it's the same type of thing here
what the actual frequency
will be determined by the tuning system
presumably what i'm what i'm
trying to spitball here is like if you
say music note of b
and then as if for example sub value you
ask for a
frequency attribute should that work
yes by default this should that thing
should have default
values but that that's you know the
middle octave and it's the
uh what i'm asking is should this
should this sub-value kind of thing be
the way to do it or should we have
specific functions
i'm not sure i think we may need some
functions i mean in the case of dates we
have this notion of date value
right i mean it depends how ornate these
functions get
yeah the the advantage of the sub values
is that we don't have to introduce
a gigantic flurry of functions i know
but the question is how many functions
if there are three or four
we might need it yeah
um right but okay but
so here these are defaults they won't be
i mean unless what we imagine is that
there's going to be some association
that gives you know things like tuning
system which is a possible way to do it
we were we're kind of toying with the
idea uh you're saying music note would
be
um one alternative that we had
as kind of cumbersome and clunky as you
were mentioning is saying music note of
association of pitch goes to be
no no i mean come on guys
let's make it usable okay i mean yes
again turn into that as a canonical form
but it's not going to be that that you
enter that
okay no no so i was talking about the
internal representation
the music note of b should be a valid
input system for all of these options
right
right there's no arguing about that
most people on our live stream are
talking about real time stuff and
i'm pointing out this um um um
let's see uh pointing out that um
um
just a second um
um
let's see pointing out things about
real-time stuff and one of the things
that i guess i don't really understand
is
if you even say speak and
we're speaking and you know the system
is speaking
there's that has been sent to the
operating system and it's happening
as a separate process and how do you how
do you interrupt this how do you how do
you imagine any kind of real-time
feedback loop
so speak is something that was present
before and yes we don't have any control
it's it's thrown to the operating system
and it doesn't
there's nothing we can do about it
however the whole uh
framework that we built on which the
playback from the audio object is
working on for example the video gui
that we have
and relies on streams the
in principle you could and append some
kind of function that
affects the outputted values in real
time
and we've had prototypes um the the
issue that we have had
with the prototypes using kernel
functions is that they are probably not
efficient enough so we are kind of
looking at a combination of the new
compiler and using
um ffmpeg filters
um to do this kind of let me understand
what the problem is so the problem is
you're playing back a video i mean right
now if it's in a notebook it's fully
under
our control and you can just stop it you
want to
yeah so so let's talk about audio
objects since it's less data
or well audio is a more difficult case
because an audio thing
could be if i understand correctly like
a beep you know if i have a series of
beeps if i make 100 beeps then
it's just beeping and it already sent
that to the operating system and i don't
have a way to interrupt it do it but we
do have
this audio stream concept that
represents
a way of sending stuff to the operating
system buffer by buffer where we
actually have control
over each buffer no i understand that
but look look
here's here's the practical problem i
send a thousand beeps
okay then and they just boom they've
they're sent and it's going my computer
is going b
b beep right then i want to say
speak hello but my computer is still
beeping
i can't interrupt the beeps they're
already out in the operating system
and you know cycling through and beeping
and i can't tell it no now i want to
speak something
yeah what i'm talking about is a kind of
different system right
you're you're saying about generating
all the data and towing it to operate
the operating system
that's not exactly how it works right
you what we have in this
in this audio stream kind of framework
is you generate say four thousand
samples point one seconds per time
and and you control each point one
seconds at the time
so you say you have sent uh 10 beeps and
now you
you you're getting bored of them you can
just say okay don't send buffers anymore
or send buffers with a different card
you say you just say that but but
look we've got an actual pipeline we've
got a notebook which is running in the
front end
it's sending stuff to the kernel what
who's who's doing what here
the kernel is controlling what staff
goes to the operating system
what is the content the kernel has
already finished its execution
by that time so there is a pope
each buffer is is sent because of a
callback
i see so that kernel there's a thread
that's
that's separately running that isn't the
thread that i'm evaluating two plus two
in it's some other thread is that right
yes and in fact if you play uh an audio
object and you evaluate something at the
same time
the playback goes on
i understand if i do another playback
does it interrupt the first playback
okay but that's what's wrong right
that's the point i'm making that's wrong
i understand that's that's the whole
point that's the point i'm making you
don't want your computer to just go on
yakking yakking
acting acting and now i want to do
something different but i can't do that
because my computer still has
the text of war and peace that it's
trying to speak but
any time no no no i'm saying
something like speak that has no ui
well speak we have to forget about speak
because i understand that
i'm saying a thing that the or emit
sound
one of these things that has no ui
you understand what i'm saying yes and
again audio stream is the one and
um again if you have a single stream you
can
control the content of each buffer
separately
i i don't care about can control i want
to know
i've done a thing it doesn't have a ui
it's just generating sound my computer
is going whatever it's going
right now i do another thing i'm asking
can does it right now interrupt the
previous piece of audio
and start playing the new piece of audio
or does it insist on finishing the
previous piece of audio before the new
piece of audio is played
neither two then
they will play at the same time if you
do this the
the whole the both things in the same
stream it will finish and then play the
other okay
but we're not specifying a stream i'm
just saying beep
for example right
i'm just saying emit sound i'm not
explicitly specifying a stream
okay those things are completely
independent of each other and this is
why they are inadequate right
this is what well so maybe we should be
using a different mechanism for those
but the whole point is
the bottom line is presumably the
default behavior okay
so there's two possible defaults you
might want overplay
so to speak and and you know preempt
i think we even have that isn't doesn't
emit sound have those
have those options even i think
undocumented yes
okay i mean have you guys looked at the
mit sound and so on or did you just
build your own
um so we wanted more control as you said
because of what you were
i understand that but you didn't you
didn't make the right
we have we have looked at it but it
wasn't an easy
quick transit in fact we started
developing uh
from the old stuff but uh it wasn't
inadequate and it wasn't easy to just
convert all of those
right so that's the thing that we got to
be looking at i mean we can't just build
a third system here right
there no no no one is arguing about
building a different playback system
absolutely
okay and then so far the way i've been
looking at audio as well is that at some
point it
it becomes a primitive of sound and i
think
music could become a primitive of sound
sound could be
the outer container of all of these
right define well yes that defines the
relative timing of when these things are
being generated and so on
because you also might want to mix
something that is coming out of an
your audio generator thing that i still
think needs some design work
um and you know and something that's
coming out of music and something that's
coming out of speech
you might want all of those together
so actually now i'm curious
how do you do and i and this is
something i don't really see much of but
synthesize singing
how would that work ah
i i do not know um
i think you can do it um from the
operating system synthesizing
synthesizer there is
um but that's a place where you want to
overlay
speech and music yes um
rebecca looked at um
what is the the name of the xml file to
control those things
i don't really remember that was a while
ago
there is some xml language where you
could add attributes
to uh phonemes or words
uh in terms of pitch
the ssml ssml yes yes right
right yes we looked at that i remember
that yeah
um okay
steve on our live stream is commenting
that beep will sound over
a speak okay um and ethan is commenting
that emit sound has some
undocumented overlay or something i
think it has
maybe we should find out what they are
and document those things i don't know
why
i no we looked at it i don't think all
of them
worked the way we expected that's why
i'm saying it's
different operating systems exactly i'm
all for it steven but just that it's not
an easy project
okay all right fine all right so so the
first point here is
we've got this notion of a symbolic
music note
what i'm not seeing here yet is
these actual operations
um the the thing i had in mind is that
all of the
operations or most of the operations
should be achievable
with the usual functional programming
zoology
cases pattern matching um
replacement absolutely yes but but then
okay well
so this is a question of whether you
know whether it's like
graph where you don't expect that to
work because it's a different structure
whether it's more is music
a list of notes answer not completely
it's got chords it's got you know
annotation and so on right
and he has a different level of uh just
a temple sequence you have
things and you could have things in
parallel which list doesn't really
um right wow right
well i mean right and i mean that's what
we're doing
with you know with sound we've got the
notion of things that are chords right
because
those are those are i mean we have a
notion of a
of a time base in sound
that you know right you can have a chord
by having just two notes that sound at
the same time
so the the idea of a chord object is
actually pretty sensible um
well except it isn't it isn't because as
soon as you have a chord object
your cases thing find me all the b-flats
isn't going to work well
why because the code should be made up
of music no it won't work
because you do cases it will be working
at some particular level
it's you know it's not even clear what
it would return yeah i was thinking
cases of
applied uh with infinity as the last
audio it won't work
it won't work because if you do that
then
you know then then you'll get sort of
all pieces all the way down you'll get
the voice that has the b
flat you'll have the the um the measure
that has the b flat et cetera
this music note has to be flapped out i
understand that i understand that but
but
but it's still a big mess you've got to
say music
chord either music chord or music note
blah blah blah i'd say that it's just
music notes i see
be composed i'm suspicious about whether
this is going to work
right so so let's just think about this
for a second because
because you know for example given a
musical score
what are some symbolic operations you
might want to do with it wouldn't you
want to you know transpose it into a
different key yes right transposer is
like the obvious um right so let's
understand what
is actually involved in doing that
because
you know philip has made the statement
that a c sharp is a c
sharp and it's burnt right into the note
so changing the key signature
and expecting the thing to kind of
ripple through isn't an
option like you have to actually go in
and change that
the transposition is just a change of
the key signature and then
adding an interval
to all nodes well i understand that but
that's a big messy operation
i mean you you know there's no very
obvious
way to do but deserve a separate
function for sure
okay give me some other examples of
things you might okay so that's an
example of something you know transpose
this piece of music scroll up i i had a
list of random examples that i
we could think of if you scroll up
further down
i thought they were down okay no i think
up in the first section
there was an applications that is closed
oh okay that was that sounds like that
at the very beginning
okay
okay yeah i'll
find out what key a piece of music is in
because what is written on there
uh on as the effective key yeah
statistical analysis of the notes
yeah and that key could be a
time-dependent
result as well
um
the complaints from calais on a live
stream that we're we're too high level
or maybe two low levels starting with
notes i mean that the point is the whole
point is
there are multiple different you know
audio
like graphics like images
you know there are different levels and
forms of representation i mean one is
you know as a you know as a as a
time series of of you know amplitude
values
this is you know a note is a great big
thing like a like a font character
is a great big collection of pixels um
that is supposed to have some meaning i
anyway but but um and actually fonts
are another interesting example because
fonts have styling and so on
right which is um in other words you can
do an operation
on a piece of text abc for example
where all you care about is those
characters abc
having nothing to do with whether
they're in you know 18-point
font of their italics and so on right
and so similarly here that sort of an
analogy to the
symbolic music is like operating on
those
you know characters without knowing how
they're rendered that make sense
i mean yeah that's reasonable i mean i
mean there is an
additional uh intermediate step between
those two levels which is the
interpretation of the musician
so but yeah those two what do you mean
by that
so you have the score as the first basic
step and you have how the
uh musician interprets the square and
then you have how the musician renders
this curve which is how the instrument
plays out and is recorded
i don't understand the intermediate case
i mean in the end
you're going from a score to somebody
playing that score
yes and what i'm saying is that somebody
playing is two aspects right one is
how that that for example what adagio
means
for intel and stuff like that but but
that's not
how do we how do we expect to you know
it's a big
fff thing right somewhere there okay how
do we actually turn that into an
amplitude level
yeah i mean that is one very good
question we'll have some
kind of heuristics i guess but no but
that's not clear that that's right i
mean in other words what you're saying
is
okay so there's a completely different
thing i don't know how people represent
that
in these whether those are basically
just textual comments
in these music xml things and so on i
mean in other words
those instructions what are those called
in music those instruction things
but the metadata like that what is that
i just what's the name for it it has a
name right there's not one name there's
an articulation
dynamic there's no generic name for the
meta
the meta uh well you could call it
performance data in a way you know
that okay all right but but so then
is there a canonicalization of that
performance data that is
you know a ffff thing is that
is there some symbolic way of
representing that that is commonly known
are chucked into their music xml file as
um attributes but but other but they're
adagio or something is that is that a
known is that you know
keyword 75 or something there or is that
just
typed as letters
da i'm not sure how xml does it i think
it is typed as letters and then so it's
just a textual comment
i'm trying to understand it's a textual
comment or it's something that's
supposed to mean something to the
to some symbolic layer of interpretation
that is something that is supposed to
inform the playback of for example a
synthesizer or
a human
so it should have it should have a
meaning for
even a synthesizer
well no no i i understand that i'm
asking
the question look okay we've got several
levels here
we've got the you know the notes as
written
you know we've got the
okay we got the notes as written with
certain timing information
and presumably some annotation of those
notes
you know play this staccato or something
right that that the annotation can
happen
at the level of individual notes it can
happen at a variety of levels for
measure for whatever else if i'm not
mistaken is that correct
i think that is accurate okay so
do you imagine that every
one of these symbolic objects will have
its own collection
of sort of potential uh
kind of modifiers that operate at that
level
is that correct i
think so the one and i'm going to ask
you the question
if if i've got some overall you know fff
specification and then i extract one
note from there
does that note somehow automatically get
that fff
or is that note a free floating note
that if it were put into a ppp section
would be you know would be different
something if we decided these are
attributes of the node then
that is uh but i'm not asking that
question i'm asking the question
how does the inheritance work what are
there things which are symbolically
specified
which do not which are not fully
qualified right
because they're they are they are
dependent on context
what that note what that you know music
note
c means depends on a bunch of context it
depends on the fact that it
was inside this voice that said it was a
trumpet
right and you pull out that that music
note c
and you stick it in the thing that says
that is a is a violin
well does it become a violin or does it
end up being a trumpet
violin unless the fact that it was a
trumpet was specified in the note rather
than in the measure okay
fine all right so then so then what
we're saying is
that we've got this hierarchy of
specifications
where a thing if it is you know a thing
itself unless it has been
forced down to have that information i'm
sure there are cases
of this where we're kind of taking
something where there's a
a sort of symbolic hierarchy like this
and we are or not forcing things down
yes yes what the other case of this is
um so the one that has caused
many headaches for us um is
how we know for example uh if you have
to notice the
tide what is the representation of that
we don't really have a
concrete answer yet i think we need to
think more about it there is a kind of
annotation that
informs it is but
it is more of an a rendering a score
rendering property
rather than a a playback rendering
property if that makes any sense
but the thing which is the the the the
over paran
between two notes is that what you're
talking about yes
and and and what are you imagining how
are you imagining that that would be
represented at the symbolic level
one of the options would be an attribute
of a specific node so
if how would that work exactly it would
be tied to the next note
um next in which next note exactly this
is if you extract it what does that mean
anymore
does that attribute survive or is it
alive only
in relationship to that look i mean this
stuff must all be have been figured out
to some extent in music xml
so we need to go through yes try to
understand how we would translate that
into our symbolic representation but
then music xml
they don't really have the problem on
the standalone note so the tie
is an attribute of a single note and it
could be a tie backwards or a tie
forwards this this is they don't have
the single note
extracted from the context problem for
them
for music smell and node is always in
school
um okay i have a practical question
which is that i'm supposed to go to some
other meeting here
um and i'm going to i mean we've got a
lot more to figure out
for sure um
so one thing i want to point out is that
we should one good starting point as you
said is figuring out music
xml and lillypawn notation and being
able to do
input expert and understanding of those
kind of data and that will inform us
many decisions i would say
right but i also it's very important
that we also be able to do
sort of the basic music theory stuff
that wolfen alpha can already do
yeah and that we don't have that be so
unbelievably complicated
that it's you know and i mean basically
these disembodied notes
that are like disembodied symbolic
points and things
somehow i mean it's quite interesting
that that um
i mean you know curious fact i suppose
is that you know in the historical
sequence right people have made maps
in antiquity i think music notation
comes from about 1000 a.d
so it's an early notation but it is um
well i'm i'm just trying to understand
what what the best analogies are
you know to what extent it is like
rendering of characters in you know
rendering of text
to what extent it's like geo positions
to what extents it's like dates
these are all patterns that we have some
understanding of
yeah um i mean like like but you know
each one of these things has has
complicated messy things like
recurrent dates like you know geo
positions on asteroids that aren't
ellipsoidal you know all kinds of weird
stuff like that
yeah i can make a comment that's not
particularly useful
here we're only considering western
music theory
so there's a whole gigantic set of music
that we're completely ignoring at the
moment
well what do you mean like balinese
gamelans and things that have weird
tuning whatever systems or your
ways of notations and different music
theory at all or
indian music japanese traditional music
all stuff that i don't really know very
much about but i know it doesn't
completely fit
in what we're discussing well it'd be
nice to not get
wrong what we're doing here to the point
where that's unrepresentable
yep um but yeah that is a much
much much bigger question how to make
western music theory work for other
kinds of music or vice versa and i
honestly i am not qualified to do that
right but i mean it would be nice to
know for music xml presumably people
have
poked at that issue yeah i will
investigate what music
xml does for different systems of music
right okay unfortunately i don't agree
that these are the
i mean the other important set of goals
here have to do with doing pure
simple you know i want the such and such
scale
i want to do this i want to you know
these things that are
uh what's it called i mean that the you
know they're all these kind of
theoretical frameworks um like there's
this giant book i have a what's it
called topos of music or something which
is some
some giant theoretical framework about
um
just about thinking about scales and
things like that
um i mean there's there's plenty you
know even before you start stringing the
notes together to make music
there's plenty we've got to be able to
figure out
um
fair enough um
i'm thinking i see various comments here
from george
about i strongly suspect some of the
people on the school
are uh do compose music so
we we might have that um um
let's see
um ah george on our live stream is
saying indian classical music is not
renderable in midi
hmm wonderful
i mean i i think you could because maybe
but it has
it may be tuned it may have a different
tuning system because midi at least
when i lost viewing system a different
different number of
notes right you the whole micro tonal
quality of
india i know so so midi at least when i
last looked at it which was a long time
ago
only had integer note specifications so
you can add
um pitch bending to each node
so you could i think represent
any kind of frequency but it is
extremely cumbersome
um right you you don't have a
note-to-note correspondence you have
several nodes correspond to the same
node plus different offsets
which obviously is crazy
right um okay what's our next step here
i mean we've we've got it seems like
you know this was just an introductory
discussion um
so one question that we have is
like how to prioritize this over video
right that is uh give the complicated
question
because i don't know all the all the
different criteria but
i mean to me this needs some design
yes okay i think that being able to do
with the
deal with the sort of individual note
basic music theory stuff
seems fairly straightforward and so long
as we have a design
but i just thinking about that i think
might hinder then the ability of
stringing those notes into a skirt
i i know that's why i'm saying that what
i'm suggesting is
let's get a design for the whole thing
right
then let's in terms of implementation we
can start on the basic music theory
which will already be immediately you
know
kind of renderable in using our sound
note mechanism
okay if we do it right uh yeah again the
the whole time control of that is not
no no no no there's no time control all
we're doing is we're saying
play no no no no it's really simple
it's really simple generate you know i
want the sequence of notes that
correspond
to the g minor scale that's it
what i'm asking is you're talking about
harmony rather than than melody
like not considering the time evolution
well okay
so i don't know i mean that's a good
question
right you know does each note play for
0.1 seconds or how does that work
right or is it a symbolic amount of time
that is then subsequently specified
but you know yes i'm saying
one thing that would already be very
useful right which is an enhancement to
our existing sound
note mechanism would be to say i want
the you know the you know g major scale
or something
right give me the notes for that yeah
that's already useful we don't have to
build any of this other stuff to do that
but so long as we have a representation
of music notes that it's going to work
in this much more elaborate music score
system
we can do that and that's the thing that
would be pretty straightforward we put a
lot of work into the wall from alpha
versions of this
we've got all the data tables we've got
all of the you know
little algorithms for doing this you
know we can implement that
i agree but the point is that the stuff
that is evolving involved from alpha
is not really compatible with the square
and this is why i'm saying
that a good starting point would be
trying to understand as much as possible
and
import as much as possible i'm sorry
what do you mean it's not compatible i
mean it's it's
what are you talking about the the
details of its representation
are not what we'll want to use but
there's tons of code that does things
like
you know figuring out uh you know that
has
tables of of um you know
things like that yes right i mean and
there's also non-trivial code
to do with you know what is this chord
i i don't know i mean there's a there's
a bunch of detailed stuff there i don't
understand why you say it's not
compatible
what do you mean the whole what a note
is
structure um no i have no doubt that
it's different i mean it'll be some
simple symbolic representation
that isn't the same symbolic
representation but
you know i can't imagine that's going to
be terribly complicated computation
about pitches we can definitely reuse
right but i mean i think that's where we
want to start so i mean the way i see it
is
we start by having something where we
can deal with notes
where right now we have something that
says sound note of c sharp
right it's it's a very simple thing
that we can't reason about it all right
we couldn't say
you know transpose that move it up by
five semitones we can't do that
right we don't have a way to do that so
i i think the first step
is to be able to do those kinds of
things i mean think about it this way if
we're doing image processing
first thing you do is is you know color
manipulation that's the kind of thing
we're talking about
i think i think i agree with you i i
just was being trapped up by
language here uh because i think what
you're really talking about is pitches
rather than notes
perhaps but it's symbolically named
notes
i want to know that five semitones above
c sharp is
so i would call those pictures rather
than noise no i mean i thought
pictures were things like you know 440
hertz
no not necessarily okay right fine but
okay
but this is the language problem i think
we agree on what uh
that this issue should be reasonably
simple
right but so then i think that the the
workflow here is
first try to get a little bit more
fleshed out
the the overall symbolic design out of
that will
fall this representation of music note
whatever maybe it's sound note
and and a bunch of functions that just
deal with what you're calling pitch
manipulation
yeah right and then
you know which will be things like
generating scales
you know moving by a certain amount
etcetera etcetera etcetera so that's
first step
seems to me another step is
you know how do we handle well there's
all kinds of things to do with time and
how long a note plays for what's
what's in accord with what those kinds
of things we have a representation of
that
in the whole sound sound note system
um you know maybe there is a more
symbolic representation that is needed
yes okay so we should figure that out
that's sort of another level up
right and similarly with notes right now
we just have you know 0.1 seconds
but we don't have you know this is a
boy you know i learned the stuff in
england where they're called crotchets
and quavers and things like that
i think in america they're called half
notes and things like this
right um they're
not that i know much about this at all
but the the um
um but but okay so so you know when you
say
a half note or something right now we
only give a number of seconds we don't
we're not we don't have a mechanism of
saying
this is a half note yep there is a
fundamental thing to be able to specify
okay well
right but so the way we think about that
is in
sound note we probably want a symbolic
specification of that time so a quantity
specification of that time for example
so 0.1 would be 0.1 seconds you know
half note will be a half note
maybe music note would have a different
default for what that second argument
means
and it would be the note you know
the note specified duration rather than
an absolute duration
you see what i'm saying that there is
crucial having being able to specify
this no but i'm i'm giving you a
particular thing so
sound note the second argument is the
time in seconds
right how it works so music note
might default but you might be able to
give sound note a time
in note numbers so to speak in some way
i'm saying using a quantity
yeah right i'll have to
think about the compatibility between
the two specifications no no no
no no no no look look the whole point is
that is not telling you
by default there has to be some
overarching thing that says
you know what the metronome setting is
so to speak
right which which is going to tell you
the conversion between notes and
actual time making sense
whereas and what i'm suggesting is a
difference between music note
and sound note sound note is a raw you
know
note with a default specification in
seconds
music note could have a default
specification and i don't know what
they're called you know note
note times so to speak yeah yeah sure
right and you know but but you can
um uh
okay there's a there's a question here
um
uh
let's see um
sandra is asking that uh is saying carlo
that uh you have a great accent i agree
the combination italian scottish i don't
know what it is anymore
it's really it's really a classic
excellent
excellent um
uh anyway somebody is giving
a um oh okay
yeah that's that's interesting right
i think that that's i mean we people
have built a variety of these things
for for representing um i don't know
whether they're things in the function
repository are there things in the
function repository
relative to i think something like that
is just already involved from alpha as
well right
it is it absolutely is i just don't know
where i i don't know whether that's
exposed in the function repository and
arguably it should be i mean because
that's again
you know that type of thing like draw
that piano view that's very useful that
is
an easy and easy thing to do i agree but
but
i mean see the thing is okay this is why
i'm pushing back a little bit on this
discussion in general is you know there
are hard things to do
and there are easier things to do and
let's not you know let's not forget
the easier things which are already
extremely useful even before we
tackle you know we've been meaning to
tackle sort of the full
symbolic representation of scores for at
least a decade
and it's obviously hard and you know we
shouldn't
sort of block on that and not do the
easy no i agree this this representation
of um
um is uh um
um yeah i mean the you know the the
being able to draw these kind of
pedagogical representations is very
useful
and you know for example we don't have
we have some capability more from alpha
to draw um you know i mean we obviously
have this basic
rendering of um of musical
uh notation um
and uh you know obviously we should
support that in some easy way look
perhaps the first thing to do
is to get into the function repository
functions that do things like that
picture this picture
and so on you know and and try to build
up from there
using with some simple music note
representation
and just you know make sure we have the
code
that does all of these different things
before we
solve the full problem of music scores
and so on yeah
well carlo if you recall the whole music
package from alpha is in kernel now
yeah no i am aware that's that's there
we have looked at it
um i'm just unsure if i agree we
we should start we could start doing
smaller things easier things first
just let's not lose the big picture so i
think that i'm i'm pretty confident that
the fundamental big picture
is the sort of hierarchy of symbolic
objects that starts with notes and so on
yes i don't want though the thing i want
to avoid is
doing the easy thing and then the easy
thing made the difficult thing even more
difficult
i don't think that's going to happen
because i think that we pretty much
understand what the
look the one thing you need to check is
things that are you know
note to note communication so to speak
things that where where that hierarchy
isn't going to work
those are the things i'm concerned about
and that's something we should look at
in music xml try and look at it with
other music traditions
then the western one that more of us
understand um
the uh you know check that that
hierarchy still works if it does
i think the coast is clear for doing
things that just work at the level of
individual notes yep
and um okay
uh priority stephen that we touched on i
told carlo earlier this week we do
10 20 max on it before 12 3 so that
other projects yes we need to actually
make look the getting
function repository entries for
things that have been in alpha for a
decade doesn't seem incredibly difficult
nor does it even seem like carlo is
necessarily the person who has to do
that
um but i think you know making sure that
we have a reasonable design which i
think is another
you know if you come with a more
detailed analysis of music xml and so on
um i think that was my thought for the
next step right i think we can nail that
in another hour probably
um of making sure we're not making any
heinous design mistakes there
then i think the coast is clear to go
and start making functions that deal
with what you're calling pitch
analysis you know pitch computations
and then take it from there i mean
yeah i mean i i think you're
yeah i mean the question of to what
extent we can use
generic symbolic computation things like
cases and position and so on to figure
things out i do not yet know yet
or whether we're going to have to have
things which are more specific just like
you know even with strings we don't get
to use generic cases we have string
cases so to speak
yeah i just don't know we don't have a
hierarchy
of heads inside them with this we would
this is why i'm kind of
optimistic but i also don't know yeah
i'm not sure
i i think that needs to be figured out
all right
um i need to run gosh
um uh
well good start much to do
um thanks everybody and thanks to
everybody on the live stream
and um uh oh look i'm signed up to do a
a science and technology q a for kids
very different thing in one hour
after two other things i'm supposed to
do so i need to run off now
thanks guys thank you